hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today I'm going to answer the question
is English really a Germanic language if
you've seen any of my videos on Germanic
languages like my Afrikaans video like
my Dutch video like my German video or
like my North Germanic languages video
then you probably saw that English is
also a Germanic language but a lot of
people write comments expressing some
confusion over this they write things
like Paul are you sure it's a Germanic
language are you sure it's not a Romance
language well that's a good question if
a native English speaker who had never
learned another language before had a
look at a page of French and then had a
look at a page of German or Dutch they
would probably be able to understand
more of the page of French or if they
had a look at a page of Spanish or a
page of Italian they would probably be
able to pick out a lot of words that
they recognize but on the other hand if
they looked at a page of Dutch or German
they probably wouldn't be able to pick
out as many without deciphering the
words a little bit first so in that case
why is English a Germanic language and
not a Romance language in the field of
linguistics languages are categorized
according to their genetic relationship
genetic relationship means that they
have a common ancestor and therefore
they have some common features that
distinguish them from other groups of
languages this type of genetic
relationship between languages can
commonly be seen in the grammar and
syntax of the language but the current
vocabulary of the language is not really
taken into account in its categorization
even when a language has a huge number
of lone words and its vocabulary changes
a lot that does not change the
categorization of that language so
because English developed from
proto-germanic it is a Germanic language
despite massive changes that have taken
place in its vocabulary the vocabulary
of English has been highly influenced by
Romance languages Romance meaning Latin
and any language that has developed from
Latin like French Spanish Italian etc so
how much has it been influenced well
English vocabulary is 26% Germanic and
it's 29% French wait you're telling me
that there's more French vocabulary than
Germanic vocabulary even though it's a
Germanic language that's odd oh but wait
there's also 29% Latin vocabulary so
that means together 58% of English
vocabulary comes from Romance languages
wow that's more than I thought another
six percent comes from Greek another 4%
comes from other languages and four
percent comes from proper names
I can't really think of any vocabulary
that comes from proper names
aside from Randy so if we ignore the
origins of English and its grammar and
syntax and just focus on the vocabulary
for a minute then English is largely a
Romance language how did so much romance
vocabulary enter English much of the
French vocabulary entered English after
the Norman conquest of 1066 the Normans
spoke a regional French dialect called
old Norman or Norman French the upper
classes in England spoke French for
around 300 years English was influenced
by the Norman French dialect but also by
Parisian French due to its prestige and
cultural influence in the following
centuries huge amounts of French
vocabulary entered English and it lost
much of its old English vocabulary but
in many cases there are pairs of
equivalent Germanic and French
vocabulary but within those pairs
there's often a slightly different
meaning or usage for the Germanic word
and for the French word an interesting
example are the pairs of words
representing animals versus foods that
come from those animals the animals are
represented by Germanic words and the
foods are represented by French
loanwords for example cow comes from Old
English coup but beef comes from French
woof pig comes from Old English picking
up but pork comes from French paw but I
don't know what the pronunciation would
have been like in Norman French sheep
comes from Old English chez up the
mutton comes from Old French Muto snail
comes from Old English smile and
escargot comes from Norman French
escargot French also influenced English
because of its huge cultural influence
on Europe from the Renaissance period to
the end of the nineteenth century and
even now to some extent but it's not
just French there's also a lot of Latin
vocabulary some Latin entered Germanic
dialects in their early days through
contact with the Roman Empire on top of
that some Christian missionaries were
present in Britain in the 6th and 7th
centuries and they introduced some Latin
religious vocab into English many Latin
words were also borrowed during the
Renaissance period and also during the
Scientific Revolution of the 17th and
18th centuries when many new words were
coined
coined meaning newly created new words
were coined from Latin roots prefixes
and suffixes to represent new concepts
in science in technology and in industry
so English is a Germanic language which
absorbed a huge number of French and
Latin words yes basically but some
people have a different theory some
people think that English is actually a
creole language there's something called
the middle English Creole hypothesis
there are big differences between Old
English and middle English of course
there was the importing of lots of
French vocabulary but that alone does
not make it a creole language but there
were other changes to the grammar of
English which became highly simplified
there was a lot of simplification like
the loss of most mountain cases and
gender so that aside from the possessive
form with apostrophe s and the plural
forms most nouns in English don't have
any inflection also adjectives used to
have inflection but that disappeared too
the word inflection means changes to a
word to represent different grammatical
categories for example the word cat and
the cat's paw here the apostrophe s is a
kind of inflection to show possession
and we have one mouse but two mice so
here the word is inflected to show
plural so let's take a simple phrase
like the good king and look at it in Old
English in Old English notice that all
three words in this phrase can change in
the nominative case say gol de Kooning
in the accusative case so nee golden
tuning in the genitive case fast golden
tuning is in the dative case thumb
golden tuning so the definite article
changes the adjective changes and the
noun changes depending on the case but
the article and adjectives also change
depending on the gender and the case
endings are different depending on the
gender let's look at a similar phrase a
good queen say or go Dec win the golden
Quin fat a golden Quin thought I go down
Quinn notice the different feminine form
of the definite article and the
adjectives this is just an example of
the grammatical complexity of Old
English so you can imagine how much it
became simplified by the middle English
period most of these forms had
disappeared or merged together so now we
just have a genitive case and the others
form a common case this is the type of
simplification that happens when Creoles
arise so it's very possible that Old
English underwent a process of
creolization inserting lots of French
vocabulary into an old English substrate
or underlying structure but there might
have been a different reason for that
simplification of English some people
don't believe in the Creole hypothesis
and they point to things like some of
the irregular forms that still exist in
English like irregular verbs or
irregular plural forms in a typical
creole language those forms would have
been regular eyes but of course
creolization is not an all-or-nothing
process it's possible that English was
partially creolized well let's look at a
couple of sentences in English and let's
look at the influences we can
let's see if there's more Germanic or
more romance influence this one's a
newspaper headline Trump pushing
immigration plan meets with family of
women killed in 2007 push this word
comes from old French would say or
modern French who say immigration this
word comes from Latin immigrant
plan this word comes from the French
word claw which means map or ground plan
meat this comes from Old English mitten
with this comes from Old English with
family this comes from the Latin Familia
according to the source I used but
there's also the French word from me
which I suppose could be the source of
this word comes from the Old English
half or off woman this comes from Old
English women or women kill this might
come from the Old English
kweilyn to quell in this word comes from
Latin so out of those ten words five are
Germanic and five are Romance words but
let's have a look at a more casual
sentence because I have a feeling that
newspaper vocabulary tends toward
romance vocabulary more than common
speech I had lunch with my friend and we
read some books I
this is Germanic comes from Old English
each had this is also Germanic it comes
from Old English hub bun lunch the
origin of this one is vague but it seems
to be from a modern English dialect word
with this is from Old English with my
this is Germanic it comes from Middle
English meat or mean friend this comes
from Old English Freund and this comes
from Old English ond or owned we this
comes from Old English way read this
comes from Old English an add-on or they
done some this comes from Old English
soon book this comes from Old English
book so this time all of the words are
almost all of the words are Germanic so
it's interesting that the majority of
English vocabulary comes from French or
from Latin but in the most commonly used
words in casual speech there tends to be
more Germanic vocabulary this is a good
argument in favor of English being
classified as a Germanic language so do
I think that English should be
classified as a Germanic language well
by a linguists criteria yes but most
people don't really care about a
linguist criteria they just care about
the practical application the practical
use of the language and in practice I
think the vocabulary is a very important
element of the language so I think it's
fair to say that in practice English is
a hybrid language it's partly Germanic
partly
romance but that's my personal
conclusion I'd like to know what you
think do you think that English should
be considered a Germanic language or do
you think it seems more like a Romance
language leave your answer in the
comments down below be sure to follow
Lange focus on Twitter on Facebook and
on Instagram those are places to kind of
keep in touch with me between videos and
I also post some little bits of bonus
content on those social media channels
and I'd like to say thank you to all of
my patreon supporters especially these
people whose names are on the screen for
they're especially generous monthly
pledges thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]
you